oh
all right we are talking wi-fi and check
out this bad boy man this box
is
big
from asus the zen wi-fi pro xt-12
wow that's a big box for wi-fi system
it's a tri-band wi-fi system up to
covers up to 6000 square feet it's got
up to 11 000 mbps in terms of its speed
11 000. think about that for a second
my plan at home is a one gbps right and
that's probably what most people are you
know consumer size 11 000 mbps
is a lot it's a lot
maybe if you're a business you have that
or maybe if you work on the star trek
enterprise you would have that but us
common folk don't have this anyway
neither here nor there it means it's
future proof tri-band what does that
mean gives you 2.4 gigahertz five
gigahertz point one and five gigahertz
point two that's right so you get
tri-band in this uh you have a 2.5 g
ports in the back of this so if you want
to plug directly into the devices you
can you got a nas drive you've got if
you want to plug this into your pc
whatever you want to game and just want
direct connection you can do that as
well
you have all those options there
this is a very interesting wi-fi system
and it's got all the bells and whistles
and it should for the price point
because this is not cheap this is quite
expensive because some wi-fi systems are
really inexpensive this is on the
top-end premium end from asus but it
delivers beautifully designed black kind
of a kind of a square kind of
design it's about this tall so it's not
the shortest and it's not the most
inconspicuous note out there but it
looks good it's black for the most part
then the top got this sort of this
acrylic square glass to it it looks kind
of like a prism inside of that that's
where you see the antennas at and then
you have this asus logo with a little
bit of design that lights up a bit but
it's not overkill it's not rgb
it's not going to be rog territory or
anything else like that it's just more
subtle but classy lights are out you see
the glass box kind of glow a little bit
but that's it really really nicely done
one of the more beautiful wi-fi systems
i've seen on the market probably in the
top three in terms of looks in my
personal opinion is this xt12 it looks
the business but it's stacked man it is
completely stacked with all the ports
that you want on this uh so as i
mentioned before you want to plug this
in a variety of different products you
can do that it is a mesh system where
you can connect to other asus routers as
well as long as they're as they're
compatible but because this is a 5g one
and five g2 it is an 802.11 ax system ac
system
uh and all the legacy bands are in there
as well so you are covered for a variety
of different products and also the
distance because they're claiming six
thousand square feet coverage for two
nodes that's pretty impressive because
in my home here i i use the tp-link deco
x60 great router system especially for
the price when the best bang for your
dollars you're going to get out there
but i need about three nodes to cover me
from the various different rooms and to
have that coverage that i want but i do
lose a little bit of speed because of
those notes
with this two nodes covers my entire
home with no issues at all i probably
could get away with one
but it would be a little bit challenging
in some of the farther rooms in my
apartment but outside of that
i think two's the safe spot and it does
it's just tremendous it's fantastic this
video is brought to you by secret lab
here at geek culture we love our secret
lab chairs especially the all new 2022
titan evo with its revamped 4-way lumbar
system for enhanced back support if you
leather 2.0 isn't your cup of tea then
consider the all-new soft weave even
more soft and breathable than before the
chair comes in more colors including
this lovely frost blue the titan evo is
even magnetized allowing the head pillow
to stick on the headrest without straps
of course there are even more new
features so do check them out at
secretlab.com
no dropped signals whatsoever and it's
easy to connect that's the thing about
these things you know a lot of people
get into wi-fi six systems you know when
they're thinking okay wi-fi six i'm
gonna get the speed all this kind of
stuff but is it gonna be so hard to
connect too if you haven't had if you
don't have a mesh wi-fi system in the
past few years you probably are scared
of connecting these things up you don't
you use an app you download the asus app
and you're up and running in seven
minutes you are up and running in seven
minutes it is that easy
super quick asus has made it easy now
there are you can get some more of those
uh
technical settings inside of there you
can separate all the bands if you want
you can have a 2.4 band that's dedicated
a 5g point one band that's dedicated or
5g point 2 band that's dedicated you can
rename them different passcodes you can
do different all those settings you can
do all that to your liking right it's
all there or you can just dummy proof
the whole damn thing and just let it go
auto and it will just
depict what band you
thinks it's best for you so you don't
have a choice between 2.4 or 5 gigahertz
now the reason i separate mine
personally is i want this i want the
fastest speeds and a lot of times even
though our smartphones our tablets our
pcs our laptops most of the new products
are 5g compatible and they run the best
on 5g sometimes they will go to 2.4 if
you set it down to automatic mode so i
tend to kind of you know be more manual
in that regard
but once you have a setup no issues at
all but one thing to take note of if you
have any legacy products let's say wi-fi
lighting systems that are older a couple
years old maybe inexpensive they're
probably running on the 2.4 gigahertz
bandwidth so it's something to keep in
mind and if you're trying to sync those
up to your wi-fi system and you can't do
it you're going to have to separate
those bands anyway so that's something
that's in the instruction manuals for
these lights so do a little tip or trick
right there for you as well okay um what
else to talk about in terms of the
system in terms of the speeds speeds are
interesting because
speeds are never what they put on the
box never
never 11 000 mbps it's like 10
gpps
i mean i don't work on the starship
enterprise i don't have speeds like that
we'll never see them probably in the
next couple years who knows but i have
one in gpps so what are my speeds like
realistically if i'm right next to the
main node which is next to my modem i'm
around 7 to 750
mbps in terms of speed right next to it
now here's the thing with mesh systems
whenever you put a node to it you know
the second node or the third node et
cetera et cetera expect your speed
speeds to drop anywhere from 40 to 50
percent
yes 40 to 50 percent
this one i dropped about 25 to 30
so i went from 700
to about 450 almost 500 on the second
node which is impressive for me
very impressive my user experience for
the past couple weeks has been good no
drop signals all my devices will say
most of my devices connect most of them
do
um i found that 5g.1 is better than 5g.2
for the devices i have and these are all
the latest iphones macbook pros
uh
ipads other products in that nature
they all work better on 5g.1 i don't
know maybe 5g.2 is more future-proofed
and
products aren't developed for it yet but
as it stands right now if you do get
this try 5g.1 as your de facto and i
think you'll be very happy with the
speeds you get out of it as i mentioned
not all my products connect to this
wi-fi system that good why
interesting um
as i mentioned some of these wi-fi
lighting systems case in point i have
the terabolt display cabinet behind me
right and these are actually
lights that connect to wi-fi system so i
connect it to an app on my phone and i
can change the color you've probably
seen various different colors here on
the channel red blue yellow orange et
cetera et cetera well
it won't connect
i've tried everything i've tried
dedicating the 2.4 gigahertz band i've
tried turning off the firewall i've
tried you re changing the security on
this uh wi-fi system
and the end result is that what this one
needs it wants wpa
to psk or something like that which
there's no psk option in this and it
also wants it to be uh
you don't want n turned on you can have
n turn on you want ac but you can have
n there's no option for that in this
system because this is a very modern
system so
i basically cannot connect to this
router with my lighting system so if you
are one of these people that have some
of these wireless wi-fi lighting systems
in your home
and you know they're inexpensive 20 30
40 bucks connect your wi-fi your old
legacy router
double check before you
fully invest into this if it will
connect to this wi-fi router because i
think this is so new
that you can't set all the settings you
want inside of it to be like a router
that came out two three years ago that
would work with these lighting systems
i'm outside of that though i really
enjoy the performance of this as i
mentioned great no dropped uh signal out
of it great coverage two nodes covers my
entire home
very easy to set up
uh speeds are are good for what i need i
wish it was faster but it is what it is
i mean that course it comes with faster
you know speeds for my internet
providers but 1gbps is kind of the norm
right now for fiber optics so
yeah i'm happy i'm a happy camper so i
would i invest in this
and i would say it depends on your needs
honestly if you need
the range and you don't have a lot of
nodes in your home
then this is an option if you need that
wi-fi six capabilities for having
multiple devices connected to your wi-fi
system without dragging it down and
that's essentially what wi-fi six does
uh then and you want good performance so
if you have let's say nas uh storage
drive system in your home uh synology
whatever it may be if you want to if
you're a hardcore gamer you want to do
some hardcore media uploading and files
and you want a direct connection to your
router you can do that as well with this
and you have the options for faster
speeds this is an option to look into
but if you are just on a budget and
you're like look i just browse the web
once in a while i watch a little bit on
netflix i don't care about
you know all these things i don't need
the best the top speeds i just need good
connection then you could probably save
some money and go for another option
asus has a lot of other options but it's
with other brands as well so this is not
going to be for everybody but it's going
to be for the ones that want the best of
the best and you want that top of the
line from asus or from any router
manufacturer i think this is probably
going to be one of the top three on the
list thus far for 2022. anyway those are
my thoughts on this xt-12 system let me
know your thoughts in the comment
section below are you looking to pick up
are you gonna say now pass away for
something else love to hear from you
guys with that follow us on facebook
subscribe to us on youtube like this
video helps us out a lot take care stay
safe
and i'll chat to you soon
[Music]
[Applause]